on ne cesse de demander des explications
à la russie concernant ces mouvements de
troupes que ce soit l'union européenne
les états unis ou encore le g7
les autorités russes se sont déjà
exprimés sur ce sujet en expliquant que
tant que ces troupes restées au sein du
territoire russe personne n'avait rien à
leur dire
le ministre russe de la défense a de son
côté dénoncé la présence de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de soldats
américains de l'otan aux frontières de
la russie européenne c'est-à-dire de la
baltique à la mer noire des forces
importantes de l'otan sont concentrées
dans les régions de la mer noire et de
la baltique au total jusqu'à quarante
mille soldats quinze mille armes et des
équipements militaires comprenant de
l'aviation stratégique sont concentrés
et prêts de notre territoire
en réponse à l'activité militaire de
l'alliance qui menace la russie nous
avons pris des mesures appropriées
le vice ministre russe des affaires
étrangères accuse ainsi l'alliance
atlantique et washington de transformer
l'ukraine en véritable poudrière dans ce
qui ressemble à une stratégie délibérée
parce que les états unis sont notre
adversaire ils font tout leur possible
pour saper les positions de la russie
sur la scène internationale
nous ne voyons pas d'autres éléments
dans leur approche à notre égard on
assiste donc à une accumulation de
forces armées d'un côté comme de l'autre
ce qui multiplie les risques d'un
incident d'une escalade
et ce n'est probablement pas un
rapprochement entre l'ukraine et l'otan
comme semble le souhaiter le président
zelensky qui va apaiser les choses c'est
tout du moins la position de moscou